la nouvelle est tombée ce lundi 1er
février le tour européen et la
fédération française de golf ont annoncé
la tenue de l'open de france 2021
le rendez vous avait été annulé en 2020
suite à l'épidémie de covile 19 la joie
alors tout simplement je pense que c'est
un c'est à une vraie très bonne nouvelle
on va dire de recevoir de nouveaux
devoirs sur le sur le calendrier
l'european tour
l'open de france à paraître ce une vraie
bonne nouvelle à la fois pour les
licenciés à la fois pour les
collaborateurs du golf national parce
que voilà ça va redonner à
un objectif commun de travail et de
préparation pour cet événement qui est
un beau tournoi quel tempo tournoi qui
est vraiment à apprécier adoré des
joueurs du tour cette 104e édition sera
organisée du 6 au 9 mai à saint quentin
en yvelines le rendez-vous connaît donc
un changement de date
le dernier open de france avait été
organisée en 2019 en octobre dans des
conditions automnales
cette fois ci les joueurs connaîtront
une météo printanière et data sont
bonnes c'est le mois de mai à moi de
même en étant région parisienne on sait
que ça peut être tout tous formidables
ou a peut-être un petit peu moins mais
c'est vrai que c'est une bonne date pour
nous un globalement ça arrivait un petit
peu tôt dans la saison mais on a un
parcours qui qui a bénéficié de voilà
d'opérations de préparation la ryder cup
qui font que le parcours sera après on
fera tout pour que par contre après mois
de mai oui les dates devraient également
attirer les meilleurs golfeurs français
le numéro un tricolore victor perez 34e
mondial a déjà annoncé sa venue pour
nous l'open de france déjà sur ont
réussi à avoir les meilleurs joueurs
français qui comme victor perez sont
parmi les joueurs mondiaux mais déjà
c'est réussi c'est vrai que pour nous
avoir un plateau de joueurs français sur
l'open de france est une c'est une
excellente nouvelle une belle chose pour
nous seul inconnu désormais la présence
ou non du public sur cet événement à
l'heure actuelle aucun spectateur ne
devrait être présent au golf national